por él
[Música]
bueno
guau cama
y bueno
y
[Música]
me lavé mira tú no
[Aplausos]
de la miel
el salvado
grande me soplará
corona
el corazón de agua
[Música]
bueno
y de la tierra
i
[Aplausos]
bueno bueno
los coches
de noche
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cantando
aguas
[Música]
aguanta
aguas
o
de agua santa dame claridad del coraje
para poder seguir en este viaje con la
gente por la tierra la vida que se
aferra con la gente por el lado de la
gente por la piel agua santa agua santa
a whatsapp tatami claridad y coraje para
poder seguir en este viaje de agua sana
aguas
por qué
n
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pienso como la verdad veloz pero siempre
atento y como culebra cambio de piel
cuando es el momento moviéndome en el
tiempo lastrando lo que siento vacío mis
propios movimientos como el viento y
sanmiguel legítimo here to be be tepito
aleja toda la maldad y avienta a mis
enemigos
a descansar perrito dirigirme hacia el
centro permíteme sentir esa tranquilidad
quiero decir la verdad permite llegar a
mis adentros permíteme dejar de hablar
tanto mediante el yang
permíteme olvidar por qué
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aguas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aguas claridad y coraje para poder
seguir en este viaje con la gente por la
tierra y por la vida que se aferra
[Música]
mi corazón es de agua
y permíteme ver qué hacer
míreme desaparece y ya no quiero que me
engañe malamente permíteme estado bien
siempre siempre siempre la corriente
tiempo siempre cierto siempre el agua va
[Música]
más
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
ah
[Música]
hola
ah
[Música]
y
siente el milagro como un taladro de
espacio el perro ya la policía dando
locaciones básicas
como me colocan procesiones se hace más
largo están dañados golpeados por años
de momento pueden estimar
[Música]
tras descansar valores estimados sobre
los mojados lluvia con olas de los
diablos lágrimas deshielo viene jugando
bien en saltando caen solos van dejando
mientras olvidan y llegando a solas
y abasolo
y ya va a sonar
[Música]
y abandonar
el agua de llevar a mi lado
[Música]
y por combinar términos para ti lo que
se le fue la visita mira siempre escucha
escucha esta final maría inés con algas
marinas como cuando la pena que mi claro
tres sistemas nerviosos aparte comentó
es muy caluroso innovar
e
[Música]
te vas
el agua se llevará la vida
sí
[Música]
será
calidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
vamos a comenzar a bailar hasta el cielo
y romper este piso
[Música]
es un gusto estar acá compartiendo con
estos expositores de increíbles pero
especialmente con esta gente increíble
que está aquí dispuesta a vibrar
[Música]
arriba arriba
tiembla la piel van llegando los días
por amor
va llegando
[Música]
un espíritu
ver que no naciste mira para bajar a
frei le lleven tu espíritu viene
encendidas hermosa luna veneno de
serpiente se llama la libertad más
pero la triste mira para bajarla frei
para bajar la frente no no va a bajar la
frente no no no no para bajarnos para
bajar los papás no no no voy a correr
voy a correr voy a correr voy a correr
yo voy a correr yo por la cordillera
donde a mi madre llaman la guerrera
donde mi padre lucha [ __ ] me requiera
defiendo la selva con fuerza de pantera
fuerza de pantera
bueno
a parte de padre
podrá quitarme lo que quiera
pero no tu sueño para manipular mejorías
podrán quitarme lo que quiera
pero ni en sus sueños por la particular
de cordillera
cordillerano
[Música]
verano
demonios de la selva salen de la bruma y
hasta parece que viene bajando el [ __ ]
huma sigilosos caminamos camuflados de
madera cerca en la ribera negro cual
pantera que espera la noche servicios de
su trinchera pide un ejército de fieras
llegó el momento de seguir adelante
cuando el canto de la selva casi
perdieron solidaridad te dará la señal
es como las de el agua turbia vistes
escamas árboles nos protege con su
programa la luna decide quedarse en su
cama va a dejar el avionazo del programa
[Música]
para allegarnos lobiano
ah
[Música]
y
ah
[Música]
bien
caminando por la calle del pueblo cura
qué nivel de calentura
del corazón
[Música]
qué locura no el sol brown y una bandada
de laurent el azar tú
bien
y es que la raza ya no aguanta más la
tortura cuánto durará
ya estamos todos púrpura y hasta en
pueblos exacto él va a ser sulfuro para
rizar que nadie vea no se apaga
voy a cantar que lloren con cultura yo
voy a cantar que baila en concierto voy
a cantar la tormenta y amador a todos a
la calle entre los monos
yo
el ayuno
declaramos la cordillera
tú va bajando mi amor tú me vas quitando
el calor y la lluvia el como el agua es
como el agua en aragón la cordillera
trabajando mi amor
quitando el calor aguacero que revienta
la amazonía gris sin pena tú me hiciste
una brujería ya lo ves ves crees sabes
lo que es sabes cuanto yo daría por
sentir esa calidez tan fría como el agua
de la tierra tan impenetrable como el
centro de la tierra
es como es tu mesa
cuando pierdo las luces de esta
es como es como voces de los brocheros o
sin embargo no está brillando como
estrelló a jugarse a gastar dejando a
todos los santos para que va entonces
vino no sé no vamos a hacer la pausa
ante ella esa lluvia parte mueran los
árboles
necesito esta tormenta para relajar
[Música]
para arreglar
i
no eres
por tanto mi amor en tu me va a quitar
en la cordillera cordillera por la
cordillera de las lluvias
[Música]
y
bueno eres como el agua de la cordillera
trabajando mejor que tú me vas quitando
el calor
tú me vas tú me va a quitar nueva no me
va a quitar tu me va a quitar
el calor
[Música]
ah
muchas gracias solo máximo